ah thank you so much inviting me here to
speak today we are going to be going
through a lot to learn we're gonna be
looking at measuring your social media
success so get your pen and paper ready
to take notes and turn off all of your
different devices so that you don't miss
anything so I know as much as the next
girl how easy it is to get distracted by
emails texts and social media so on this
webinar we are going to be going through
everything that involves measuring your
social media marketing success you're
going to learn how to set SMART goals
for your social media marketing and how
to differentiate between vanity metrics
and actionable metrics we also go
through each social media goal and how
to measure it what keep KPIs to keep an
eye out and how to use the results from
all of these measurements at the end
we'll also go through some of the most
useful tools that you can use to measure
your social media success now let's get
started
just like with any of your marketing
efforts social media marketing is an
investment you spend a lot of time every
day managing it and thinking of new ways
of improving your results you're
spending a lot of money on social media
tools people to manage it consultants or
so on and you're also using social media
marketing to get results whatever those
may be the only way you can ensure your
time and money are well-spent and that
you're heading towards achieving your
goals from social media is to measure
your results to put it simply there are
two main reasons why you need to measure
your social media online first so that
you can see whether the resources you're
investing in are paying off and second
so you can see what is working and what
isn't which in turn will help improve
your social media strategy because of
this measuring your social media success
is more than just a means of controlling
your spending and making sure you're not
throwing money away as something that
isn't working as you wanted to rather
it's a way of identifying what works and
what doesn't so that you can use that
knowledge and get better results from
social media in the future most
marketing
are easier to measure for example so
you've created an ad campaign you can
easily track all of the clicks the ad
got as well as the conversions with the
built-in analytics similarly if you're
sent an email to your lists or in an
exclusive offer you can easily track
your clicks on that link and who bought
with social media marketing though
things can get more complex it's not as
easy to measure some of the common
social media goals the reason for this
and what makes measuring your social
media ROI so challenging in some cases
is that not all of your goals are easily
quantifiable particularly monetarily
consider engagement for example
engagement is extremely important and it
is often a clear indicator of a
successful social media campaign but at
the end of the day it doesn't exactly
bring in any income directly or at the
very least not one that you can measure
accurately so how can you know whether
your social media marketing is
successful it's quite simple really
by setting clear goals if you want to
measure your social media marketing
results you first need to set your goals
from social media ask yourself what do
you want to achieve think about it this
way if you don't know what you want to
achieve how can you figure out whether
you've reached success or not achieved
in it as the case may be so before you
start measuring set your goals now these
could be to increase the amount of
traffic to your website to increase your
brand awareness to drive more
conversions and make more sales to find
more qualified leads to increase loyalty
and build a community of brand advocates
to manage your public image and your
customer service or to gain social media
influence now quite a few girl setting
techniques that you can use but one of
the best ones in my opinion is the smart
way with this technique you're
accounting for everything first be
specific the more specific you are the
better for example if you want to gain
more traffic you would use something
like increase in my facebook traffic by
20 + then just so you want to increase
your traffic in general won't be of much
help
and you won't be able to accurately
measure your success so if your traffic
have increased by two percent for
example does that mean your campaign was
a success be specific and if you can
include some numbers or the better next
your goal needs to be measurable
otherwise how will you know whether
you've achieved it and when it comes to
social media marketing it can be
particularly challenging to measure your
goals goals also need to be attainable
when you set a goal ask yourself this
can I actually achieve this goal or is
this just what you're thinking how
realistic is your goal for example you
might want to double your conversions
from social media in the space of a
month but is that really achievable or
are you setting yourself up for failing
social media marketing takes time to
grow so you need to be extra considerate
of the attainability of your set goals
be true to yourself is your goal
relevant when achieving this goal make a
true difference to your overall success
how are achieving this goal or failing
to achieve it impacts your overall
business objectives and values and
finally is your gold time-bound you need
to give your goal a clear deadline but
be careful that it's a realistic
deadline one that can actually be
achieved as I mentioned earlier social
media takes time to grow and provide
results so you need to take that into
account when setting your deadline when
setting these goals be honest with
yourself
don't write more than you can chew and
don't expect everything to happen at
once before we go any further I think
it's very important to make the
distinction between vanity metrics and
actionable metrics energy metrics o that
you will usually make you feel good
about myself I think number of followers
or likes your profiles but at the end of
the day they can't actually help you
make any decisions regarding your social
media strategy sure it's great to have
more followers but what can you do with
that information
after now while these metrics still
matter it's much better to focus on
actionable metrics these are metrics
that by contrast allow you to take
action
an example of such a metric is traffic
what are ways that you can use it is to
focus your attention on one social
network that consistently brings in more
traffic if that is your goal or when
looking at all of your different content
you can learn about what types of posts
tend to drive the most traffic and use
that information to take action no need
to create more of those types of posts
while leaving the post that don't bring
in traffic other actionable social media
metrics that can be found are the number
of clicks the number of leads you find
or the number of conversions you make
now that you've got all of that out of
the way let's look at each different
type of goal to establish the main KPIs
that you will need to measure in order
to measure your social media success
social media is a great tool for
increasing website and blog traffic you
can use it to promote your blog posts
and other content to promote your
exclusive offers create giveaways and
competitions and to promote your
services or products with a goal of
getting more traffic to your website
thankfully it's also one of the easier
and more straightforward goals to
measure first make sure you know exactly
what your goal it's such an exact number
right for example to raise your traffic
by 10 percent on Twitter in two months
the more specific you can be the better
then it's time to start tracking your
success one of the ways that you can do
this easily is by using a custom URL
such as Google e or bitly or there a
word of warning with bitly others can
also check your stance by adding a plus
sign to the end of the link so I would
personally recommend using googley use a
URL shortener for all the links you post
on social media going to your blog or
website although the analytics the URL
shorteners are limited it will allow you
to see exactly how many clicks your
links got the best way in my opinion is
to use Google URL shorteners in
conjunction with Google Analytics Google
Analytics you'll be able to get a much
more detailed account of your traffic
from social media not just how much
traffic you're getting but also the
quality of that traffic you can check
your total social traffic by going to
acquisition then all try
quick and finally channels then click on
social to see a more detailed account of
where your social media traffic is
coming from exactly alternatively you
can also check your social media
analytics by going to social and then
network referrals when you go from
acquisition though you get more
interesting stats about your traffic by
measuring your social media traffic you
should also consider the quality of that
traffic after all people are clicking on
your links but don't spend more than a
few seconds on your website then that
traffic won't be of much help to check
the quality of the traffic look at the
bounce rate and the average session
duration to find out how much time they
spend once on your website if you have a
very high bounce rate from a source you
might even be better off focusing more
of your attention on the social network
that brings in less traffic where that
traffic actually stays on your website
for a few minutes or even take some sort
of action another way of checking your
traffic sources quality is to see
whether they have completed any
conversion goals except go around
analytics allows you to set different
goals such as having the visitor buy
something or make a reservation for
example then you can also assign a
monetary value to your goals by to set
up goals you will be able to track your
conversions much easier but I'll go into
that in a little bit more detail later
on another useful tool from Google
Analytics is the user flow here you can
see because that care what party of
social media traffic took on your
website to check the user flow through
your social media traffic click on where
it says country at the top of the use of
load then click on social and finally
click on social network you can then
highlight the traffic from any social
network to see what they're part of
website social media is a great tool for
getting your name seen and heard by the
right people everyone and their mother
is using social media so office business
is a great platform for increasing their
brand awareness the beauty of social
media is that you can reach all of these
new demographics and connect with all
sorts of different people without having
to spend a fortune on ads and all kinds
of other marketing techniques it's a
more organic way of getting your brand
in front of the right or I
the question now is how exactly can you
measure brand awareness admittedly is
not nearly as easy as tracking your
social traffic but is also not
impossible to measure the first instinct
of course is to check the number of
followers however we've already talked
about how your following number is
mostly a vanity metric one that might
make you feel good but ultimately it
won't help you make any decisions or
take any action not to mention follower
numbers are not always that accurate
just because you've increased your
number it doesn't mean that those
followers are in any way interested in
what you have to say harsh may be but
very true for example on Twitter so many
people only follow so that they can get
a following back and unless we take a
more in-depth look at your audience know
me their interests and their industry or
niche the number in itself doesn't
really matter they'll give you an idea
of your you know how you can increase
brand awareness you can use other
matches to check whether you've achieved
your goal for one you can once again use
Google Analytics while I'm increased in
traffic can be a sign of increase brand
awareness it's actually other metrics
that can help better Terman your
involvement although it doesn't
necessarily mean the results are
correlated with your social media
marketing efforts particularly if you're
using other promotional tactics it can
however give you a better idea of your
success and it can be used in
conjunction with social media analytics
I'll show you how in a minute
so I'm Google Analytics go to
acquisition then all traffic and
channels to see your direct traffic this
is traffic that didn't come to your
website by somehow entering your URL
directly in the address bar in the same
place also check your social media
traffic how many are new versus
returning me this will help show you
whether you've reached a larger audience
and in a meaningful way that they are
willing to check out your website but
the best way to determine how successful
you are in social media in terms of
brand awareness is to use social
listening or monitoring if you will you
should set up a search for your brand
name it's not everyone is going to use
your hand or we're mentioning then you
should check for us how many mentions
you've received and this is one of the
best indicators for brand lens the
number of followers you can get can also
be an indicator for brand awareness it
is not a particularly effective one as
we talked about earlier rather you
should take a look at your following
versus engagement instead of looking at
how many followers you have check to see
how your following and your engagement
of both revolving together if you're
operating a larger territory not just
one city you can also check to see what
new regions in regional social media use
a tool that can analyze your followers
in-depth and make a note of their
locations worldwide the more new
geographical regions you're reaching on
social media the more you're increasing
your brand winds while getting lots of
traffic is great that's not where the
money is the money is in making
conversions finding leads and making
more sales after all don't we all want
our website traffic to take action this
could be anything for example signing up
for your newsletter watching an ad or
video stay on the website for a
particular length of time buy something
download an e-book or other freebies
sign up for a free trial but at the end
of the day what constitutes as a
conversion is completely up to you just
so long as the visitor takes an action
that takes them one step further in the
sales funnel issue is it's a little bit
more difficult to track on your success
with social media conversions everyone
we discussed setting goals in Google
Analytics this is arguably the best way
to track conversions to set a goal or go
to acquisition overview and then click
on get started under set up a goal you
can then use one of their available
templates or create your own custom goal
there are four main categories to choose
from first there's revenue related guns
these can be signing up for a
reservation or making a payment or
appointment next you can set up an
acquisition goal meaning someone created
an account or signed up those can also
be inquiring for example when a visitor
checks out
or service page when they check out your
contact page or your business's location
quite an estimate or they check your
inventory or schedule and finally you
can also set up an engagement goal which
means that the visitor played some sort
of interactive media on your website
such as a video or product demo or a
sideshow but to set these conversion
goals you can also assign them a
monetary value so that it can be more
accurate when measuring your conversion
success now they'll be able to see by
going to acquisition or traffic and then
all channels what your goal conversion
rate is how many goal completions were
achieved and the total monetary value of
those conversions from social networks
if you are using new generation cards
such as on Twitter for example you can
easily track your new subscribers with
the social networks built-in analytics
social media can also be a great source
for finding qualified winners
I think where in popularity there might
be coming directly to you or finding you
on social media it can be that you're
looking for leads you'll serve for
example by using social media monitoring
to measure these results you need to
keep track of every qualified lead you
get in our social media I would
recommend getting a custom customer
relationship management tool where you
add all of your qualified leads then
group these leads with tags and comments
that identify them that's coming from
social media you can also use Google
analytic goals once again to track
conversions focus on the following types
of goals so when someone signs up for
your newsletter or subscriber list or
any other program available on your
website or blog when someone checks out
your product or service page as well as
your contact page or your business
location or when they viewed a sales
related video or slideshow on your
website many businesses use social media
simply so that they can interact and
engage with their audience engagement
although it doesn't bring in any income
directly it's still one of the most
important aspects of a successful social
media presence more people interact with
you organically the bigger the chances
that you are achieving in the other goal
from social media marketing more
engagement
more kicks and more traffic it can help
you improve your reach and ground
awareness and it helps you gain much
more social media influence and much
much more
thankfully it's also one of the easiest
social media goals to measure to track
your engagement there are a few main
metrics that you need to keep an eye out
for first there's the amount of mentions
you get ideally you shouldn't rely on
the mentions you see on the particular
social networks analytics page or what
your social media management tool tells
you as I mentioned earlier some people
will mention your brand name without
using your social media handle and the
only way to track all of those mentions
accurately is to perform a monitoring
search for your brand name most seasons
your media management tools such as the
gorup pulse or sprout social do this or
you can use the dedicated social media
monitoring tool right brand 24 or brand
watch which can perform more in-depth
searches across several social networks
for the rest of the matrix you need to
check to gauge your engagement you can
use the social networks built-in
analytics and most social media
management tools that also offer
analytics
check to see whether you're getting more
comments how many people are taking the
time to leave a comment on those social
media posts how many likes are they
getting and any other important metrics
like how many shares or retweets are the
post getting through continuous
engagement with your social media
friends fans and followers and by
consistently posting great content you
can start building a community of brand
advocates and loyal fans branch out
because are amazing tools to health
there's nothing more effective than
having a regular person with no vested
interest in your business promoting your
business to their friends and followers
word-of-mouth continues to be one of the
most effective forms of marketing now
that we have social media word-of-mouth
can really be taken to the next level to
track the amount of brand advocates you
have your business you can use a tool
that tags them as such automatically
such as Agora pulse they provide a
customer relationship management tool
which automatically highlights any brand
ambassador
following that said most social media
analytics tools and also tell you who
are your top users these are the users
that are consistently sharing your
content with their own followers and
interacting we keep track of the growth
of these numbers to find out how you're
evolving over time and once you've
identified your brand advocates make
sure to engage with them and try to
reward them in some way to keep them as
your advocates and ambassadors by
growing these relationships you're
increasing your chances of them
continuing to help promote your business
and among their followers sharing your
content and engaging with you all
completely for free as opposed to using
social influences another common use for
social media is to manage a business's
public online image and their customer
service most of your target audience are
likely to be using social media so they
are also likely to check out businesses
via whatever social platform they might
be using not to mention people are
increasingly using social media to ask
businesses questions about their
products or services as well as to make
comments about them and even complaints
because of this businesses need to be on
top of these mentions and respond to any
customer service issues as soon as
possible not doing so can be damaging to
our overall brand image but if you're
quick to respond polite and most
importantly truly helpful can actually
be very beneficial to your image for
example look at this exchange between
Sainsbury's and a customer who wanted to
buy some buttered fish from the popular
supermarket chain but the product didn't
have a barcode what would normally be a
cusp and a customer services who turned
into a hilarious conversation between
the two filled with fishy puns which
attracted a lot of engagement and
positive attention towards Sainsbury's
now the question is how good are you at
managing your customer service the best
way to determine this is to use a social
media management tool that also provides
tea management capabilities and
analytics there
you'll be able to track exactly what
each team member managing your social
media marketing is doing how long it
takes each one to respond to mentions
and questions and what the response rate
is like whether you're an entrepreneur
or have a business or even if you're a
regular person social media provides a
perfect platform for growing your online
influence by becoming more influential
social media will be that much easier to
forge relationships with social
influencers in niche as well as to gain
more engagement more followers more
brand advocates and more traffic to your
website it can even help you become a
fault leader in your niche and it will
be easier to get people to trust you and
your business how can you measure social
media influence though as you probably
can't expect from me I don't think it's
the number of fans or followers that
determines your influence you can have
hundreds of thousands of followers but
if they're not actively interacting with
you showing your content engaging in
conversations and so on then those
numbers don't really mean much to check
your own influence you can start by
using a tool like clout what it does is
study your entire social media presence
and your metrics to give us a score to
your influence basically the higher the
score the better and although it's more
of a vanity metrics the science behind
it is pretty good and it can give you an
idea of your progress towards achieving
influence the more your score improves
the more it shows that not only are you
active on social media but they are also
likely to be getting more comments and
mentions like another way of determining
your influence is to look at how your
engagement levels evolve over time are
you starting to get more shares and
retweets for your social media and blog
posts are there more people leaving
comments on your posts or trying to
engage in conversations with you are
people starting to come to you with
questions about your niche now the
gone through all of these different
social media goals and how to measure
them the question now is how can you use
these results why do you need to measure
them and how they can help you improve
it's not enough to just measure your
social media success but you also have
to use this knowledge to further grow
your success as I mentioned towards the
beginning of this webinar one of the
main reasons for measuring the social
media ROI is so that it can help you
improve your overall social media
strategy when you're measuring for any
social media goal try to also identify
what exactly is helping you achieve that
goal or alternatively what is keeping
you from achieving it to put it simply
you should use your social media
analytics to find what is working and
what isn't then you can use that
knowledge to focus more of your
resources both time and money to focus
on the things actually work here are a
few examples of what you can learn from
carefully studying your social media
analytics and from measuring your
results with social platforms work and
which don't work if you're using a few
different social networks to promote
your business you should check to see
which one works for you and which
doesn't bring in any notable results you
can now give up altogether on one of the
social networks or you can simply focus
more of your attention on the one that
works best what type of content gets you
the best results just like with blogging
your overall social media success will
be largely due from the content that you
post if your content attracts people's
attention and it gets them to interact
in some way such as by sharing it with
their followers or leaving a comment
then you're that much closer to
achieving your social media goals in
order to improve your success you should
carefully study your social media
content to see what works and what
doesn't and once you do try to find the
common link between your most successful
content as well as among your least
successful content why does some post
get more shares more likes more comments
and how can you replicate that success
it could be the format of the post like
for example your followers tend to
prefer images or it could be the actual
content of your opt-in check
any big boost in engagement or social
media traffic what is their cause it
could be a particular pose that you
shared that was very successful in your
audience or it can be that the right
person shared one of your pose once you
identify the cause use that knowledge to
try to replicate the success again in
the future
generally it's a good idea to focus a
lot of your attention to the post you
share on social media and what makes
them successful or as the case may be
unsuccessful afterwards the content you
post at least a more engagement more
shares more comments and so on now let's
go through some useful tools that you
can use to measure your social media
success I already mentioned a girl pulse
once or twice throughout this webinar
and the reason for it is because I think
it is one of the best social media
management tools but also because it has
some very useful analytics tools you can
use it to track your brand awareness
over time as well as to see your
publishing your engagement stats
together so that you can get a better
idea of how your efforts compare with
audience engagement in terms of audience
in science they provide a very capable
CRM tool what I like most about it is
that they automatically tag any social
media influenced influences or brand
ambassadors that are in your list as a
class you can organize your followers
with tags and notes so you can keep
track of qualified leads from social
media and other important fans and
followers you can also analyze your
content in depth in order to find out
what your best and worst content is in
terms of its success with your audience
our goal posts can track your team
management metrics as well so that you
can see what your response rate is how
long it takes each user to respond to
customer service issues and so on
quickly is the professional social media
analytics platform so you can get very
in-depth details and analytics for
facebook twitter youtube google+
linkedin instagram and even broths
basically you can use it to track
everything that is social media you can
customize your dashboard as you like and
even adjust metrics to your heart's
design you can also set up all the
matches and KPIs that matter to you so
that you can be rest assured that the
tour's collectively for you there are
features that allow
to create a competitive benchmark
reports against industry standards or
your competitors and to track your
customer care with monitoring and
response time as occupy is a tool for
discovering hashtags top influencers in
any image and for tracking Twitter and
Instagram hashtags if you've created a
hashtag campaign that you need to track
you can use hashtag refine to track your
success and get detailed reporting on
your results at a glance you will be
able to see how many users are using the
hashtag how many tweets or posts were
sent using the hashtag how many daily or
totaling questions the tweets or posts
made and so on
brand watch also allows you to delve
deeper into social media users
activities so that you can find out key
customer insights it's mainly a web
monitoring and analytics tool that you
can use to track consumer feedback find
out what social trends are happening in
your niche that could affect your brand
or business monitor the compare customer
service issues or mentions in general
and find out what the sentiments are
granting your business or one of your
hashtags is what makes brand watch stand
out is how powerful the tool is
particularly there's social listening
tools they provide very in-depth
insights into your social media and they
also provide actionable metrics that
will help you determine exactly what
people are saying about you and your
business and what the sentiment behind
their social media update is Brian 24 is
a similar tool to brand watch you can
use it for monitoring the web but
particularly social media as a
professional work of social media
monitoring tool you'll get more in-depth
analytics and you can perform more
complex monitoring searches you can use
it to track all of your social media
mentions as well as to analyze the
sentiment behind them you can also use
it for customer service as you can
respond directly from the tools
dashboard to any customer questions then
you can also compare your social media
mentions and presence against your
competitors as well as monitor their
activity along with yours
the Trender is a social media analytics
tool that offers solutions to Boesel
big businesses as well as small or big
agencies they provide very detailed
reporting for most major social networks
namely Twitter Facebook Instagram and
YouTube and they help you keep track of
all of the most important social media
stats such as engagement content in
science audience in science customer
service and you can even use it to keep
track of your admin duties with the
trendy you can also set up automatic
reporting with the data you mean and
receive tips and recommendations based
on that data but water is a monitoring
tool and analytics tool for social media
marketers and businesses it's a
particularly great tool for tracking
your online brand awareness for example
you can use it to track your media
coverage over time make comparisons
and/or share voice with your competitors
as well as figure out what the sentiment
surrounding your brand is you can even
use meltwater to measure your are your
pure online with the advertising value
equivalency feature so there we go we've
gone through all of the top social media
goals that can be set up the most
important things to remember here is
that you need to be start by setting
goals to use your social media marketing
as soon as possible use the smart way of
setting goals to set realistic and
measurable goals and then check the
relevant metrics to measure your success
it's important as well to keep in mind
that social media takes time to grow and
get results you can't expect to boost
your results across board within a month
or you'll be sorely disappointed but
although it takes time to grow once it
does social media has the power to
become one of your top sources of
traffic and engagement with your
audience and not to mention it can also
help you become an amazing source of
qualified leads make sure to track your
results regularly particularly when you
reach the goals deadlines thank you so
much